I'm Christian Rodriguez from the Oakland
foundation and my talk commutation of
thinking in the classroom focuses on how
an educator can integrate computational
thinking into their already developed
curriculum
good morning everyone thank you for
joining us this morning especially on
this final day of tech conference talks
so I'm Christian Rodriguez I am on
behalf of the Wolfram Foundation and
today I'll be talking about some
examples and instances of computational
thinking in the classroom
so essentially what today is you're all
aware or throughout this conference
computational thinking has been sort of
a a topic of discussion we we realize
that there's a critical need for
teaching and learning of this when you
place a heavy emphasis on the student
outcome and what's in it for the
students and what's going to be the
value for them and for their future but
we in this process we're not really
talking about the educators themselves
that we have a public education system
that's a little bit far behind and is
not up to speed to regard this a new
skill like computational thinking so in
order to address this sort of momentous
challenge what do we need to do because
we are well aware that educators already
time strap they don't necessarily have
all the resources they need and they may
not even have the skills required to
achieve something but they have the
motivations the ambitions and so on to
do so so how can we address this but
before I get into all those little fun
dirty details basically why am I here so
this will be my third participation at
the Wolfram tech conference I have
nearly been at Wolfram for four years
Wow okay that's time goes on fast uh-huh
and within this last year I've partaken
his role as the project manager for the
computational thinking initiatives so
what this really means is that I've
overseen the on-the-ground efforts and
the strategic outreach for all the AI
League programs and various
computational thinking outreach before
then I helped I was part of the
the greater Wolfram research and help
develop the student ambassador and
community ambassador programs as I look
across the room I've actually had some
contact with some of you before during
those different programs so - earlier
phases and to even get before that I've
always had this interest in education
specifically STEM education access and
equity during my college years I went to
the University of Illinois I was a
researcher at the child development lab
focusing on neurocognitive testing
so essentially what sort of testing
mechanisms bring greatest alertness and
awareness to students and what
essentially creates cohesion and memory
adapted early adaptability and then
throughout that same time I was also a
technical writer at turn which was a
digital advertising startup which was
purchased by a mobi then purchased by
SingTel which some of you may be aware
of and when I tell people that I
graduated from the University of
Illinois with a degree in advertising
they sort of get this look of you
Aldermen like okay what why am I talking
to you
um naturally so why right and it's
essentially that these these extended
learning experiences and circumstances
have essentially shifted my entire
career focus where now I find myself in
this technical role and I even consider
myself a bit of an example where
computational thinking can take your
career so if there's whenever I talk to
students I tell them let me tell you my
story and why I think this is relevant
and let me tell you about the trajectory
you can potentially find yourselves in
and before I even get going with the
rest of these things let me say that I
I'm not a curriculum expert nor my
teacher but I am someone has had
informed experiences and I'm one that
has been in the classroom dozens of
classrooms has worked with hundreds of
teachers and hundreds of students and
that has given me an ability to
basically understand what are these
needs and what I can provide based on
the resources the foundation has Wolfram
and this incredible network of
enthusiasts and evangelists have so with
those I'll carry on so as I said we have
this challenge of preparing educators to
teach computational thinking for many
educators this is a discipline that's
sort of very new to them they are either
they weren't taught this and during
theirs their upbringing or it simply
they don't know how to teach it so how
do we sort of address this gap and
according with that to better prepare
educators for this we realized that we
need to understand that they need time
resources a network of peers to support
them and as well as essentially be the
support to help them guide them in this
process so the observation of these
needs promote prompt in myself and us at
CGI to add a new focus to the initiative
and that's essentially teacher training
so we initially CTI initially focused on
extra curricular programs for middle
school and high school students we were
like it is too hard to get into the
classroom it is too hard to to change
institutions so let's you know let's
settle with tapping just be some other
time let's let's make sure that we can
provide with teachers with the resources
that they might need so that they can do
this but after having several
conversations with educators and
individuals who are truly motivated
about bringing this to their classroom
we realized that okay maybe maybe
there's something that we can do so with
that we decided to start dipping into
what some of these teacher training
tools and teacher resources might look
like and our very first instance into
this
where our educator roundtables some of
you participated in these but one of the
one of the some of the main topics we
covered we're computational essays as an
assessment now we've started to hear
this term computational essays a lot
throughout this conference and some of
you might still not have an entire clue
about what that might be
I think Steven purposely leaves it as a
sort of very generic thing because he
wants the individual the writer to sort
of craft this a narrative this
exposition so how do we use essentially
this this writing tool as a way to
understand someone's comprehension and
proficiency of computational thinking so
that was the very first roundtable we we
hosted then we address how can we write
a computational thinking lesson plan to
some of you this might be a a I
adventure but to the general educator
masses the the best term to use is
computational thinking lesson plan
because it has a structured approach
where we identify the objectives the
goals what the students need to learn
and how they can go on off path of what
these what's already available then we
decided to provide be essentially the
training where if someone wants to run
this these activities on their own they
can go ahead and do that but they just
need a little bit more guidance a little
bit more confidence so that's when we
hosted the running an adventure and that
was one of our CGI ambassadors led that
discussion itself as he is someone who
has ran several of those I will add that
these are all recorded and I can make
available to everyone so you can
understand exactly what is what is our
interpretation of a computational essay
and how they use it as an assessment how
you can go about writing a computational
thinking lesson plan and how you can run
one yourself so the next step to sort of
addressing these needs of educators we
decided to
into developing a course a focused on
kind of bringing these elements of these
different CT principles and essentially
what teachers need in their curriculum
to fulfill the guides restrictions that
their school presents to them so with
the support of Russell Fuld Smith he is
a co-founder of the Acton Academy in
Venice Beach which is essentially a
school devoted entirely to project-based
learning and student centered learning
and computational thinking so with him
having this guidance we were able to
spearhead what the content of this
course is and what we would be able to
deliver to these participants and to go
into a little bit more in depth about
what these who were these participants
none of them had any Wolfram language
experience they all said I care about my
students I want to be able to provide a
learning experience form that will
impact and matter to them and I know
that conversational thinking is going to
be one of those skills that's going to
be relevant to their lives so what can I
do and how can I be supported so we
decided to build this course around 5i5
outcomes so first and foremost since we
will be using the Wolfram language we
had to be able to provide or at least
get them through a point where they were
proficient in the Wolfram language so
that they themselves could then go into
their classrooms and teach their
students now you might think what what
are we going to be doing to teach them
that and perhaps the best way to do that
was through a iwl and which most of you
all aware by this point but that itself
is not the best thing to do if we soon
realize there's because no one really
wants to learn out of a textbook
entirely you know you want to work off
of it you want to dive into your own
path you want to understand kind of how
you can play around with the different
complexities of it the following thing
is we had them craft their own
definition of computational thinking for
them to be able to understand what
this is to be able to articulate their
own definition and for them to be able
to basically explain this and teach this
to the to the class of students then we
had them create their own computational
thinking lesson plan so that they knew
how to essentially begin to integrate
their own lessons into their already
developed curriculum as well as how to
be able to run their own adventure log
so in order to sort of assess how they
were going to do this they submitted a
proposal about how they were going to
follow up on this and what they learned
and how they're going to essentially act
on that whether it was through getting
through the approval of administration
it was getting the approval of a
curriculum director how would they go
about ensuring that what they learned
was actually put to use and to talk a
little bit more about some of the themes
we addressed first and foremost what is
computational thinking as most of you
are well aware there are several
definitions that exist out there and
there's a lot of resources out there
that might seem a little bit
overwhelming at times so how do i how do
we identify a participants own mission
with their students and with what we're
doing which is what everyone else is
doing as well as what does it mean to
craft a computational thinking lesson
plan I think our AI adventures do a
pretty great job at providing a
structure for students to be able to
understand the different components of
components and principles of
computational thinking and as well as a
more specific topic of conversation
'likes so we had a forensic science
teacher we had an earth science teacher
we had a finance we had a we had a
finance banker and a few other
individuals that just completely
different topics so the point was how do
we add computation as a tool to your
course without having to change the
course entirely so we had them work on
exercises this is about
halfway through the course itself and we
said alright let's use your own
curriculum that you already have and
what snippets can you add programming as
a tool and from then on it was actually
a pretty neat exercise because the
teachers themselves for the first time
got to see what it was to engage
themselves and that deep computational
thinking process like okay I can use
Wolfram Alpha as my as my data
repository I can use Wolfram Alpha to
pull in all these historical or food
data and what a cinch ended up happening
was that this one and a half hour class
and be coming three hours because they
continued they were just working with
each other doing some pair programming
tactics and really like one up being
helping each other out making sure that
they essentially created something out
of this if you guys are in a world of
computational X it's essentially a
concept that every academic every
professional field is going to have some
component of computational added to it
and you know we're well into that curve
already then we had considered that
we're dealing with educators a lot of
times we have to consider is whether
they have they have the right
motivations whether they have the the
passion to essentially address this
issue in their classroom and make this
change so what we ended up doing was
practicing some some self-efficacy
exercises where we had the educators
write down their goals why I think this
is important and where they see this fit
and how they want to impact their
student lives basically to get a clear
understanding that this is something
that they were deeply interested in and
wanted to work on and moving on with
that it was structuring a program
basically if you can't integrate this
into your curriculum what can you do
what else can you do and what are those
components of a program that we're going
to be required logistical details
program details and content wise and the
most important part was integrating
computational thinking into the
curriculum and by that part it was
specifically perhaps the most important
thing was to take a look at
commutation of thinking principles
themselves as the guiding tool for this
integration when we look at curriculum
itself teachers have already spent ace X
amount of hours doing it they're not
going to want to completely write
something from scratch
and they're not going to want to
essentially bring in something that's
not going to excite their students or
their students are not going to care
anything about so with this we asked
them to identify certain parts in their
curriculum that they could relate one
principal to and from then on one of
them one of our educators is a social
studies teacher I can go up and she
decided to use the interpreting problem
in a way that a computer can assist with
it and using data to address real-world
situations for most of her integrations
so for their social studies course
students had to compare their modern
life style with the lifestyles of
children from another era and see you
think what what does this even mean and
why is this even question asked so
essentially they had to simulate the
experience of another child essentially
they picked someone from let's say 1800s
Australian civilization and they had to
label how exactly what were their
predicaments and what were their lives
and then they compared it to their own
lives and tried to simulate the
differences between how has life Chris
greatly changed students also reviewed
data to identify patterns and trends and
Wars and other historical events
I think the go-to strategy or I guess
problem and project with this specific
like assignment is that people want to
go directly to Google and search things
up they want to say what happened during
this battle how many people died during
this battle and what were the
repercussions of it and you don't
realize you can do this all in the
notebook you can literally pull the
information right in there and students
can really value themselves and
essentially build civilizations to
reveal the findings
students created a simulation to study
relationships and social science
phenomenon such as women's education in
health during our excuse me during our
own educator course we had students or
participants engage in a group adventure
which essentially we had them address
the issue of maximum carrying capacity
for the earth so essentially they had to
bring in all these different variables
and figure out how they can essentially
address this challenge or solve these
issue and essentially that's what she
had her students do she used the group
activity from our course and brought it
back to her classroom and actually
implemented it and she saw it was
actually really nice to see because she
said I finally saw my actual skills
being put to use I learned something and
I immediately saw being put to use and
my students loved it and then another
more prominent one is students use
primary source data to study the voting
pattern or the voting the patterns of
voting rights in the nation I think it
was Seth Chandler who wrote a community
post about how we can analyze voting
trends she and essentially ended up
using that blog post to to lead the the
lesson for that day and I can share with
you guys essentially what these student
projects looks like because they were
all asked the same question but they all
came up with different visualizations of
it and that can kind of give you an idea
of how each student approaches
computational thinking differently so
the important thing here is to focus on
not trying to build a whole new course
on computational thinking especially if
you're new to this or you're new to
programming in a Wolfram language but to
understand how you can use this concept
itself break into pieces and use those
pieces to make slight changes to your
curriculum where you can help students
understand what they're doing and why
this is necessary so a lot of times just
these concepts are what can guide
students directly into these lessons
into these activities and for them to
start getting into this path where
they're well aware of what it means to
be
a tional thinkin what it means to break
down a problem what it means to
implement these questions and so on so I
think I have
I need question time